but de boult au jour c'est à m sila pour
but premier moment que qui je pense a
changé ma vie c'est la première fois que
je suis monté sur scène c'est à
l'externat des enfants nantais c'est la
première fois qu'en fait j'avais foulée
un plateau de théâtre est en phase ii
d'un public et je pense qu'à ce partir
de ce moment là je me suis dit je me
sens bien quoi je me sens bien ici j'ai
envie de
j'ai plus rue de partir je pense que ça
ça fait un déclic dans ma tête je me
suis dit j'ai envie de faire ça très
longtemps j'avais je devais avoir entre
14 et 15 ans j'ai toujours été le petit
trublion de la classe j'ai toujours été
celui qui faisait qui faisait marrer les
les copains j'ai en fait j'étais celui
quand il était absent on disait en main
ce n'est pas pour jean reprendre ses
devoirs ou ou à tiens il va m'aider pour
un pour un td non c'était à main sont va
pas se marrer aujourd'hui c'était plus
pour ça bon dieu merci je n'étais pas
j'étais pas souvent malade mais
l'anecdote en fait c'est qu'il y avait
un groupe de filles qui faisaient qui
faisait du théâtre et qui avait choisi
de monter la pièce
huit femmes et donc il manquait un
élément manqué une femme et ils se sont
dits sûrs et ahmed
on aimerait bien qu'ils fassent du
théâtre moi je dis jamais de la vie je
veux faire du théâtre pour moi c'était
aux molières ça et où j'étais encore
très novice très c'était toujours très
et j'ai testé initial et un cours et en
fait ça a été ça a été la révélation
mon père était très comme ça très
strictes très papa froid mais très
strictes ce très très conventionnel et
le jour je lui dis voilà papa je pense
que j'ai envie de devenir j'invite
devenir comédien j'ai envie de faire des
sketchs m'a dit écoute avec tes
conneries tu préfères que tu deviennes
plombier chauffagiste que tu veux mais
passe à tout mais pas ça et c'est la
seule fois où j'ai tenu tête à mon père
en tout cas pour quelque chose d'aussi
important et j'ai eu raison de le faire
et il me l'a dit après il m'a dit écoute
là bravo je suis fier de toi
donc ça a été ça a été wells a été en
tout cas un tournant puisque j'ai tenu
tête j'ai travaillé énormément pour
qu'ils acceptent puis pour qu'ils se
rendent compte que c'est vraiment ça que
que j'ai envie faire que c'est ce
pourquoi je suis fait et finalement il a
accepté et puis il en était très fier il
ya une femme qui a accouché de son
enfant devant la scène devant la scène
non je dis n'importe quoi devant la
salle de spectacle pardon
comment ça s'est passé en fait pendant
le spectacle chez j'ai un petit moment
d'improvisation et l'a donc pendant que
la lumière est allumée
je vois une dame qui se lève avec son
mari je me dis mince ils ont pas qui
fait le spectacle
donc je les interpelle idiot vous allez
où comme ça de manière un peu au talent
et au très très impressionnant
finalement vous allez au comme ça et là
le mari me dit en panique dit elle en
train de perdre les eaux et moi avec la
distance j'entends pas pas bien je dis
pardon
et là j'entends le plus
si j'ai pas entonner i'll est en train
de perdre les eaux je sais que c'est pas
vrai si c'est un truc de dingue est en
fait les pompiers sont arrivés elle n'a
pas eu le temps d'aller à l'hôpital et
elle a dû accoucher de son enfant devant
devant la salle de spectacle
en fait ça m'a marqué dans le sens où
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est c'est unique donner la vie pour
moi c'est quelque chose de deux il n'y a
rien de plus beau on donne la vie c'est
à dire que voilà c'est fait il ya un
partage ya c c'est beau c'est fort en
fait c'est un moment hyper hyper intime
hyper émouvant c'est c'est toujours un
moment très très très très beau quand ça
se passe bien en tout cas
et hélas devoir de voir ce couple donné
naissance à sept enfants qu'en plus on a
on a revu après moi ça m'a ça m'a touché
quoi donc ouais long feu j'aime pas
j'aime bien les petites histoires comme
ça qu'ils sortent du qui sortent de
l'ordinaire